>>> THIS MORNING, WE'RE HEARING
FROM SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
SAMUEL ALITO.
IS IS FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE
WRITING THAT REVERSAL OF ROE V.
WADE, SPEAKING IN ROME, THE
CONSERVATIVE JUSTICE MOCKED
FOREIGN LEADERS WHO CRITICIZED
THE OPINION.
>> THEY HAD THE HONOR THIS TERM
OF WRITING, I THINK, THE ONLY
SUPREME COURT DECISION IN THE
HISTORY OF THAT INSTITUTION THAT
HAS BEEN LAMBASTED BY A WHOLE
STRING OF FOREIGN LEADER.
ONE OF THESE WAS FORMER PRIME
MINISTER BORIS JOHNSON.
BUT HE PAID THE PRICE.
WHAT REALLY WOUNDED ME WAS WHEN
THE DUKE OF SUSSEX ADDRESSED THE
UNITED NATIONS AND SEEMED TO
COMPARE THE DECISION WHOSE NAME
MAY NOT BE SPOKEN WITH THE
RUSSIAN ATTACK ON UKRAINE.
>> ALITO'S SPEECH WAS FOCUSED ON
PROTECTING RELIGIOUS LIBERTY.
THAT WAS THE OVERALL THEME.
CNN'S JOAN BISKUPIC IS JOINING
ME NOW.
A LOT OF SARCASM THERE, JOAN.
>> IT WAS SO CLASSIC SAMUEL
ALITO, BRIANNA.
HE EXUDES A SENSE OF
AGGRIEVEMENT ALL THE TIME, EVEN
AS HE IS WINNING.
HE HAD THE MAJORITY IN THE
DECISION THAT HE SAID, WHOSE
NAME CANNOT BE SAID.
AND THAT'S THE DOBBS RULING,
WHERE THE JUSTICES ROLLED BACK A
HALF CENTURY OF REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS, WOMEN'S PRIVACY RIGHTS
IN AMERICA.
AND HE ALSO HAS BEEN IN THE
MAJORITY, PLOWING AHEAD ON ALL
SORTS OF RELIGIOUS CONSERVATIVE,
BUT YET HE CANNOT HELP BUT
ENGAGE IN SARCASM.
THAT'S HIS WAY.
THERE HAVE BEEN TIMES WHEN THE
COURT DIDN'T GO AS FAST OR AS
FAR AS JUST ALITO WANTED IT TO
GO.
AND HE EXUDED THIS SENSE OF
PERSECUTION IN VARIOUS DISSENTED
OR CONCURRENCES.
BUT ANNOW THE BREAKS RUNOFF ANDE
IS WINNING.
HE HELD ON TO HIS MAJORITY, A
NARROW FIVE-JUSTICE MAJORITY TO
REVERSE ROE V. WADE FROM 1973.
AND THEN ALSO THIS SESSION, THE
CONSERVATIVE MAJORITY ALLOWED
MORE PRAYER IN PUBLIC PLACES,
SUCH AS PRAYER ON A FOOTBALL
FIELD.
AND ALSO, MORE GOVERNMENT
FUNDING OF RELIGION.
SO SAMUEL ALITO IS WINNING,
DESPITE HOW HE HANDS.
>> SO CURIOUS TO KNOW HOW THE
CHIEF JUSTICE WOULD FEEL ABOUT
THIS.
JOAN SBISKUPIC, ALWAYS GREAT TO
HAVE YOU.
THANK YOU.